welcome
thank you
hi
clifton victoria thank you for joining
us on the show
thank you for having us atlas
yeah we're excited
so pumped
so pumped
for your first podcast appearance also
which is exciting
yeah so special and
very happy that it's with you
likewise
likewise
and i'm really pumped that
because
coda
was
staying here that we got introduced
and we just
vibed really strongly and
now we are
doing a show together
yeah
yeah let's see what we can co-create
yeah and super grateful for coda for
making it happen making the introduction
exactly
and faces of the future
is
it's exciting because it's so deeply
rooted in this conscious awakening that
the collective is
undergoing
and i'm excited for you guys to share
more about
both faces of the future as an actual
program and community
and
also for us to sort of talk about what
that process looks like
in
one of the
core elements that we talked about
and that's really
familiar to people is that
there seems to be this very
tight feedback loop
between the inner
and the outer
and
consciousness being inextricable from
physicalism or materialism
and there's always these unique little
patterns that we can detect
that
if we shine the light of awareness on
them we can gain more insight and
transparency into them and purify our
behavior to come more and more from
oneness and wholeness rather than from
lack and separation
and conditioning and all this type of
stuff
so
let's have you guys speak about that
both in your own journeys as well as in
what you're
serving
people
with it's quite a start
quite an open question and always i'd
love to invite victoria to kind of share
a bit about
her journey
yeah so uh we're faces of the future we
are a startup studio
with a personal development platform
that's focused on conscious awakening
and um
how i
started with this work i guess you want
to hear the backstory or a bit about
what we do first
yes yes of both okay
so uh clifton and i met
in 2016 at a biotech networking event i
was working as a nurse at the time at
nyu and clifton was getting his mba from
columbia university and i was wanting to
leave my job as a nurse i wanted to
start my own business and i was also
going on this
kind of awakening journey i had just
been in a car accident and it set me on
a path of being more present
more aware in my body and seeing how
empathic i actually was with the
patients all the energies i was picking
up in the hospital and that was the
first time i was really able to sit and
be present with myself
feel the the pain in my body the
suffering that i've been carrying for so
many years i was able to look deeper and
start to do some of that emotional and
spiritual work
and
[Music]
it's been a journey it's been a journey
since 2016.
we
didn't do you want to try men sure sure
and meanwhile i guess as victoria was
looking inner i was looking outer
so business school i was looking at
venture capital
right after we met i was flying to saudi
arabia for a miss global forum so i was
getting really macro
looking at trends and i grew up around
newspapers in a newspaper family and
kind of
was awakened to what happens behind the
scenes and how certain things don't
necessarily they aren't necessarily as
they seem
um for headlines and whatnot and so i
was starting to not be able to forget
the the truth of what i'm seeing on the
macro scale
and so i chose entrepreneurship and
venture capital as a form of
pursuing truth
in terms of co-creating the future
and i could see that while the ideas
were great the execution
and the culture of a lot of these
companies and funds were
not necessarily in alignment with a lot
of the missions that were being said
um so
i that's kind of how
we join on the inner to the outers i was
looking on the outer and and she was
doing it in
her journey yes and and it took about
three years after that for us to
reconnect in which case i had started to
do a major inner journey in a work with
a startup that combined
different modalities of healing
and that's when we reconnected and
really
started to to sync up
yeah i started going more and more
integrative and holistic over time
really western medicine at first wanting
to help people seeing how it wasn't
serving people and the way i wanted to
and then i started exploring things like
aromatherapy first and then and then
reiki doing energetic practices really
feeling the depths
of people that aren't visible to the
naked eye but things we perceive
vibrationally about people
honing in on
all those feelings
that i was coming home with from the
hospital i was like oh wow that's a lot
and in the holistic company for me
what i was ending up doing was running
myself into the ground nearly having a
heart attack with all the pressure the
stress and my work life balance or lack
thereof and
something just wasn't clicking it's like
okay if i'm creating a company all about
health and wellness and and the people
who are building it aren't healthy uh
and and are unable to to navigate
uh the journey to create something that
brings health then there's something
intrinsically
uh
flawed in how i'm approaching it and so
that's when i began to search internally
and and switch from an external focus to
an internal focus
and really did a deep dive into the the
spiritual side of reality
and that led me to to india to seeing a
lot of unique powers of the third eye
that are becoming more and more popular
such as body scanning blindfold reading
akashic readings things like that
and
i came back from that trip to india and
that's when victoria and i actually
reconnected because i was in a 21 day
program and was practicing
manifesting the powers of the third eye
which is body scanning and then akashic
readings and so
i was there having to do it 21 times in
24 hours and i'm trying to figure out
who's awake at this time and i'm on the
west coast and i see victoria wants to
awaken yeah and victoria yeah literally
who's away
that's a good one
i like that and victoria was there and i
was like i don't really
know if she'll respond but she had
responded favorably to something i sent
about astrology
and so she was on facebook messenger and
i just messaged her hey do you want an
akasha greeting
and
she said yes
and i was in a space where i was really
looking for my purpose my dharma
i knew what wasn't for me and knew all
the things that i was not but i didn't
know who i was what i was what i was
looking for what lit me up about life
what my heart connected to where was my
heart
even and i you know went to
did the reiki training did the burning
man kind of thing and then when clifton
and i reconnected
the last time i touched base with him he
was like really in the business world
and not super tapped in yet it was what
i would say like emotionally or
spiritually and at that point when he
was going through this program i'm like
so i'd been journeying inward slowly and
steadily like what did he do what what
is this that that just made him
take a quantum leap
in his level of spirituality and
understanding of the world
so i wanted to know more
yeah and so we connected and each time i
was um
expressing through me the akashic
records and
uh seeing where there were triggers or
traumas
um and i had put all of my eggs in the
spiritual basket and completely
uh neglected the the physical reality so
that the needs
that i have of like
connection
sustenance you know movement
um
the reality of living in a place where
we we do
exchange courage change currency
and there there is a need for that and
so
my journey with victoria actually was
starting to
bring back those spiritual gifts into a
form in a context that
the the current reality can hold
and um and more importantly what i found
was the more that i did work on myself
the more i was able to stay in both
places or to utilize the skill in a way
that would help
uh others and serve them in in a better
way
i started with uh channeling you know
hindu deities which is really really
incredible
but the
applicability of the messages it wasn't
being followed through on so that wasn't
a key force multiplier there's no
integration there's no integration
sometimes there's no acceptance of what
was being said
and it was sometimes it was just too too
macro
uh on on what to do but certain
questions around business because i have
a cpa background and an mba
i was able to give extremely explicit um
guidance and that seemed to get a lot of
traction
um but at that point i still had yet to
understand or even know about emotions
so
um at an early age i shut down emotions
and so when people said they felt you
know something in their heart like a
heartache i just thought that was a
figure of speech i didn't actually know
that that was
a feeling in in the heart and so
i had to undergo an emotional awakening
after that spiritual awakening
and
through the culmination and work with
with victoria actually really helping
ground it and bringing the nurturing and
emotional intelligence
we formed
what is faces of the future
and i had emotional intelligence about
other people not about myself
because of the the poor boundary
structure not understanding what's mine
what's not mine and that's uh a topic
that's tricky in spirituality it's like
oneness versus
how do we set up healthy boundaries with
the oneness
as well
yeah
and you're you're emotionally sensitive
and um there were things that i thought
were private like in terms of my thought
and my energy that were more uh
not non-obvious but because she was
highly sensate and she could feel it she
could actually know what what energy i
was sending out to people which got me
into trouble she didn't match the words
sometimes yeah a few times and so then
it was really like whoa
this is like full multi-dimensional
integrity right here so
let's let's explore that
nice
it's pretty exciting
hearing about
all of the
ways that we transition from
mainstream
society
separation
ego
to
this turn
inward
that then
becomes infused in everything we express
outward
so another good one to ask you guys
about
would be
so now that you've went through
this these journeys
how do you
then
distill
the essence of what
you've understood
into the faces of the future
curricula and then
take
people through it and what does that
process look like
yeah i'd say the best
view of it is it's an emergent property
so it's constantly evolving and each
person's essence
if you imagine going through the process
and we're a filter we filter people's
essence
and so it's going to be different each
time
and it informs us like the order of
operation of our clients is actually a
divinely guided thing
because we're becoming more
sophisticated uh every time someone goes
through the process we're upgrading our
algorithm so to speak of what that
process looks like
and i would say that the process came as
a download or pieces of downloads that
we didn't fully we intellectually
mentally grasp what it was
and as we are doing it and as we went
through our own journeys and had the
embodied understanding we're like oh
that's why
this works or that's why that's a thing
and things that we were discovering what
we saw that we then encountered in like
joe dispenza's work in quantum
manifestation principles we encountered
it in
in psychology with needs and boundaries
and feelings
an attachment style it's like
it's a full spectrum 360 holistic view
of who you are as a human in totality
how to find your center how to find your
heart what does the heart want let's
de-condition that personality that was
formed
from the the tribal nature of society
because we we are programmed by our
parents and our upbringing and we evolve
certain patterns of behavior that tape
player that theta brainwave recording
state is going for the first seven years
of life and we don't know what's a good
program what's not a good program it
serves us in the beginning but then
after a while you see it's no longer to
your benefit and it doesn't keep you
safe anymore it actually hinders you
from moving any further
so
deconditioning that personality that
helped you get love security and
acceptance in the first seven years of
life in your tribe and your family the
family of origin to
understanding your individuality i think
it was a
er casey who said
use the two terms where i heard it and
um
finding the unique essence
the
the oneness
the core fractal of who you are and what
you stand for what lights you up what
excites you
yeah and another way of saying it is uh
bringing it back to the embodiment
we help people tap into their heart and
repair it and amplify its guidance
system in another metaphor because in
those first seven years you learn
you you adopt certain beliefs to survive
in your household like why do we do this
well that's the way it's done that's how
you learn to be a part of the family and
so after that deprogramming or through
the process of living that program and
you may have had some traumas or issues
where you shut down access to your heart
in order to survive and so then the next
step is to actually tap into the heart
repair it and repair your ability to
navigate in in in the present moment
from an integrated heart brain spirit
coherence which people come with various
levels of integration and sophistication
and we really love uh the four wheels
tire that one of our our mentors dr
brian malandine talked about which is
imagine you as a being have four tires
spiritual mental emotional and physical
to power your vehicle
and and if you have an over inflated
tire you're not going to drive smoothly
and that's exactly what happened to me i
put it all in physical and mental and
then realized i was completely missing
spiritual so i threw everything out
jumped on the spiritual tire and and and
of course there were problems with that
and then all of a sudden i realized
there was an emotional tire and so
making sure that each tire is balanced
is a really important aspect of
navigating because you're just gonna
keep having to learn
certain things in life that are going to
manifest for you to learn to inflate
that specific tire
and what was happening was i was doing a
lot of spiritual bypassing so i was
leaning into my spiritual abilities
which in in many cases bring on and
wonder like whoa you can do that
to bypass certain uh
needs of mine to bypass certain
emotional intelligence that i needed to
learn in order to move forward and i
find that in a lot of uh clients and a
lot of technology uh embedded
individuals is that they're wanting to
bring forth a certain type of society
without necessarily making sure that
their navigation system is is aligned
and that their tires are all adequately
pumped up
like not over compensating with your
strength and comfort zone and pouring
and sublimating all the energy towards
that tire yeah like you're saying and
structurally i mean we've had like areas
of focus in order to expand society so
we go deep in one area but what we're
seeing is that especially for
the the the next generation and the
bridge it's about being balanced within
yourself and understanding that yeah
pursue your passion identify your dharma
and that might be heavily skewed in one
tire but that is not at the detriment of
developing the other tires and so we've
actually gone through our programs that
we've created and it it just
humbles me to realize like it's a
continuous learning journey
and and there's so much that's it's so
rich there's there's not a stop there's
not no longer this like guru mentality
or this like infallible mentality it's
like we're all human we're all learning
and with that mentality we can have the
vulnerability that's necessary to go
deep we can have the authenticity of the
human experience and not present a
facade of perfectionism that a lot of
self-help brands may
push out there
we're being truly wrong in our evolution
and our journey
yeah and what we're finding is the the
deeper we go with ourselves and with
clients the more expansive you can then
go on your vision for
the the world we want to co-create like
what your mission is in society like
understanding where that core desire
comes from
how it got implanted there if it's
really authentic in your own and what
that looks like as the manifestation as
you're you're doing this in in society
yeah another analogy is like a tree a
tree needs deeper roots in order to grow
tall
and a lot of people are focused on on
the above surface the the tallness of
the tree yes and they're not focused on
the deepness of the roots
and they're trying to grow
without recognizing that they have to go
deep
first
love that
so good
we draw a similar analogy to the guests
that come on the show where there's that
similar style of
parsing their essence and the algorithm
continuously updates as you see more
patterns
and then
i love how you also describe in your
curricula that
there's this
what appears to be a seven or so year
period of
the familial and tribal upbringing
that
oh
yeah
there's
there's so much there that
is
it because that's really the route so to
get
to that
collectively as a
as a focus
is great because then we start in the
first seven years
with
oneness and unique expression
as
the essence
rather than only
all of the
conditioning and separation and ego and
all of those patterns
but yet yes there's also this
process of
there's a nuances here because
there's many um
there's many upbringings that happen
around the world where it's
these in the first seven years these
patterns don't even emerge
right so that's the style of like
future
pedagogy around upbringing
that's most exciting at least for me
where much of these perverse patterns
don't even emerge
anymore
because then we end up being 20 or 30 or
40 or what not years old and going like
well [ __ ] what happened in those first
seven years oh [ __ ] and i have to do
some deconditioning of my heart [ __ ]
and then
you know that's also a whole thing oh
[ __ ] those first two three four decades
i was being such an [ __ ] because of
this thing that happened when i was
three years old blah blah blah snooze
like that [ __ ] is old now like let's
move beyond that let's figure out the
first seven years properly so we don't
have to do all this
later
stuff in the middle part of our lives
and to be honest
from a spiritual perspective that's
where i feel a lot of our generation
took that on the dharma to be put in
these dysfunctional families to learn
because as as a expression of oneness
we're here to bring everyone
collectively to that and so a lot of
what you might call light workers or
awakened people i don't know what
terminology you like to use but we need
to understand the dysfunction
because we are oneness and we don't
understand separation unless we
experience it in individual states and
then collectively talk about it and go
through it
and so
yeah and that and that's really what
what we see and you're absolutely right
like these patterns are buried in our
subconscious and and we go around
thinking we're fine because we're
focused on our conscious but then all of
a sudden we look at the fruit of our
tree and we're like this isn't what i
want there's something off or all all
these areas in my life are great but
this one area
is off if you even have the awareness to
know it's off
sometimes you just you just pour more
into the the bucket or tire you're most
familiar and comfortable with
and it's like look we're here to live
our fullest life our fullest expression
and if one thing's off that means
everything's off in in some aspect of it
because the way you do one thing is the
way you do everything so there's
something for you in deep exploration of
that area so oftentimes we find
clients resonate with wanting to find
like that ideal romantic partner that
love relationship and they might have
other areas of their career really
dialed in
but it's that one aspect that is so rich
for their exploration and so challenging
for their ego to let go and receive the
feedback and
i can say as in our dynamic it's
challenging every single day every day
it's like we're going to work and
healing ourselves in a process of just
sending an email yeah
because it's clear like that's the the
level of intentionality that we've put
into this this entity this business
and and the dynamic is so so unique and
it's so rich like i just want to send an
email to confirm that this appointment
is happening but it opens up a five-hour
conversation
that brings up patterns from my past
deep subconscious resistance and wounds
things on her side as well and then we
get through it and then we clear it and
then we see it instantly manifest in how
we can help others in that similar way
[Music]
what you don't heal from your first
seven years you you find messengers and
lessons in your outer reality that
mirror from outer to inner
so anything
that's in there will transpire through
your business or through your romantic
relationship
through your friendships yeah because
it's relationship so you can have a
relationship with another being but you
could also have a relationship
to your company to your work
relationship to your your team to to
working out
so we we find so many interesting ways
that our ego has self-defense mechanisms
to essentially sublimate or or take all
their angst or
issues in one topic that they don't want
to deal with and and apply it to another
area
and especially with technologists and
entrepreneurs
it could simply be that they want to
give themselves validation but they
construct such a complex mapping of
reality that they decide to create an
entire business
around that unmet need that they that
they don't give themselves
and so it's about recognizing what your
needs are
and recognizing how to fulfill them in a
healthy way
so that way when you go forward in a
relationship you can go forward with
healthy interdependence when you go
forward with the business you can create
a business that's truly a business and
not necessarily an abstraction of your
ego that you're applying to it which ego
maniacal leaders in technology
there's there's ample
data points of that
and then also
investors as well so it transpires to
investors
as well so what we do is we say
regardless of the role you're playing in
the awakening of humanity
let's first make sure that you are
self-sufficient that you are fulfilling
your needs that you have clear
boundaries and ways to to operate
because without that you you might get
out of your lane you might
over step in what role it is that you
are here to play you may get sucked into
someone else's project
someone else's mission so
aligned with what the purpose is but not
exactly on your terms and not exactly in
the role that you want to be playing
and not with the amount of
responsibility that you want in the
pursuit of it
yeah so case in point
you know i was basically in in in taking
a bath and downloaded what this secular
online ecosystem looks like
and it's like that's great
and then i keep talking about like this
is there and then this is there and then
this is there see here's the data point
here's this future it's talking about
this and and after a while you know
victoria was like
okay but what's your role in it
and that was so challenging for me
because there's a lot to do for one
person
yeah and
and a lot of responsibility that was the
the other caveat because my mind could
think about it oh i could do this
i do it naturally but like what is it
that you're responsible for that you
want to take responsibility for i want
to take responsibility for the whole
thing yeah what do you want to opt into
that's the truest expression of you and
that was the core it was like what is
the expression of me and what is it that
my heart wants and so that's what
unraveled the the pursuit to tap into my
heart the pursuit to repair the trauma
and and the pursuit to integrate and
activate my full being which is a lot of
the the dna of what our our journey is
with faces of the future and the
fundamentals program
yeah this is really resonant
as though
we come in
with the
intention to go through
said
crazy
seven
year
intro
so that when we're 30
and
quite aware of
having healed
and integrated and transcended
through that that way we can turn around
and implement the
proper frameworks and protocols for
non-separation and for non-conditioning
and for non-ego for the
2020s and 2030s babies that are popped
into the world
it's awesome
so
i also really enjoy an example probably
for
you
beautiful person listening
of the
car
analogy with the tires this is probably
very relatable for you guys
so
it really does feel like sometimes that
we're going through this process of ah
[ __ ] i gotta feel more air into this
tire oh [ __ ] that one's over inflated uh
and you're getting these catalysts from
that are this mirror from the outside
world
and so this is why like if you haven't
done that little bit of work
with your family
it's going to show up somewhere
[Music]
as a reflection from one of your family
members or from a friend or from in your
business will show up
and so yeah if you have this little
egoic
twist or distortion of an unmet need
that you feel like you have some sort of
unworthiness or
or
that you need
a substance or a relationship or an
experience or whatever in order to feel
validated
that's gonna show up
a big mission even oh a big mission yeah
that was another one is uh look at me
with all of my concepts and all of my
projects and all of my i don't know who
i am at all but look at all of this look
at all my accounts and look at all my
yeah my toys my cars my houses yeah
so
yeah it shows up in all of these
different ways in our reality
um
being mirrored to us that we have a
process of turning on the light of
awareness on that specific area
to love it accept it heal it integrate
it transcend it and
i love that because the tire analogy is
really relatable for people maybe
there's some other really strong
relatable examples with the tire analogy
that you can share with us
because that also seems to be what
pretty much happens
in the teenage and in these 20s and
usually even into the 30s is that we
have this like oh [ __ ] like this one's a
little deflated or over inflated and i'm
gonna jump
and then for most people it's that the
spiritual tire is taking a [ __ ] their
whole life
and there's no feelings of oneness
whatsoever their whole life they're just
stuck in a
bubble reality around their head the
whole time yes no heart
no gut no emotion no feeling
just intellectual concept to concept
concept concept concept
so the spiritual tire for most people is
taking a [ __ ] and then at some point
there's some sort of insane chaotic
traumatic event
oh spiritual tire okay okay and then
that happens
that was like my car accident experience
i shared yes exactly when you're not
paying attention to the signs as they're
coming and then
[Music]
that jarring experience that forces you
to look
look within yes we call it the drill
sergeant of awakening is suffering just
yes and so so yeah so that's a classic
one is the spiritual depletion and then
so physical mental emotional wacus maybe
through some of the common depletions or
common
over
because i was just coming up that there
may be a common one of um when you meet
like really hyper um emotional people
that just have no
um idea of what they're putting into the
field
because they're just so emotional like
everything just sends them into a
discursive pattern of thinking and
emotions that then radiates into the
field uncontrollably
so that might be an over inflated
emotional tire walk us through some of
these yeah examples yeah you totally got
it so
i'll start from my own experience
because that's what i've learned is like
the best way for me to speak from truth
is my authentic experience
so for me i had i had the same thing of
no spiritual uh tire and then boom all
of a sudden i i did this program it was
like
and just like yeah
more like
right but um
everything was a spiritual thing and i
was spiritually bypassing and like oh
love and light oh don't worry money it
doesn't matter
you know oh don't worry it'll all work
out like oh you're mad well love and
light you know and
and like oh
what should we do today well let me tap
into the to the quantum field and figure
that out you know and so it's it's a bit
comedic
because of how uh how obvious it is that
that's disconnected from reality but
that's a prime example is a lot of
people or there are a population that is
like the solution everything is
spiritual the solution everything is
just meditate or just be in love and
love and light namaste
and and and and that's that's a prime
example that that you see out there in
the spiritual world so that's an over
inflated spiritual tire yeah okay
exactly
and you want to take another one
sure um
[Music]
i guess the overinflated mental tire i i
can i can speak to um kind of like
rationalizing experiences you've been
through or theoretically why something
would make someone mad even though
they've encountered it but they haven't
fully embodied it and felt the emotions
in their body that emotion gets trapped
in there and stuck and you're
disconnected from it and i was
disconnected from from it a long time
and
you
trying to it to intellectualize
intellectualize what is happening to you
and you can explain it and you explain
why something gets you madness every
time you explain it it gets you matter
and it's like that thinking feeling loop
that you were talking about but you
don't actually process the emotion you
just work yourself up to remind yourself
of the story of the narrative and it's
like your mind really anchored in that
that neural pathway it's been hardwired
and every single time it's like
this thought precedes that thought
precedes that thought and you reinforce
the pattern over and over and over again
instead of sitting with the feeling why
do i feel this way
what's what triggered me why might i
feel that way
okay what do i do about this feeling how
can i go and blow off this steam or this
anger how can i assert to somebody
in a respectful way of my own needs and
their own needs why something upset me
instead of like burying it and shoving
it back down we get sent to our rooms
all the time when we're little and we
don't know what to do with that time
sometimes we don't know how to how to
process
the experience that just happened and
depending on like parental styles if
they're there for you or if they're not
there for you it's like hey kid go fend
for yourself
sometimes you know not given the proper
tools
to learn how to unload unpackage
disentangle all the emotions like we
just remember the trauma it's a memory
it gets buried in and every time you
recall the memory the same emotions come
up without resolution
and
you remember it just as if it was
yesterday
20 years later
it's crazy yeah another example of
inflated mental tire is
dating in new york city for me
was like you go to a date and it's like
let me just read your resume oh where do
you live what do you do where did you go
to school what's your job yeah or or
uh
colleagues of mine who are really
unhappy at their their company or their
business or their current situation like
decisions that sound good on paper yeah
but they rationalize well yeah life life
is horrible but i i just have to stay at
this job for five more years and then
five more years i'm gonna do this then
i'm gonna do that and then that helps
listen everything mapped out for the
next like 20 years of their life yeah
and they they justify the reasons why
why this is a great idea like
reconvincing themselves
yeah or or yeah taking like news at face
value and like well yeah this makes
sense because this this and not checking
in with how they actually feel
about the headline or about the news or
um computer scientists are a population
where it might be more prevalent of when
when there's a group it's almost like an
egoic battle of who who can out-think
the other person and can put the most
mental thing when ultimately
they most likely want connection and and
appreciation and validation and a good
time but it ends up being this battle of
like this coding thing versus that
coding thing
um is another example of mental
wow so that also relates to this
in biology signaling theory
so you have the peacock
tails uh you know
look at my lattice work of concepts yeah
yeah
yeah
and where whereas in in reality
just by
slowing down the field dynamic itself
can there be very profound
revelations
for the entirety of everyone that's
present there
just by slowing it down
so you've noticed that so much these
last couple of years is that
the more that we just did
the the less that actually
is evolved and awakened in
that
and then the more that you just go
i'm alive
i exist
i am
you are
we are
this is
and like just that little drop
just creates so much space
you know another way to think about that
for our
especially for maybe viewers that are
less familiar with um lots of
spirituality but there's a really good
tie-in here with neuroscience as well
where
it's like
having an empty room
is when you
it was when you breathe and you just
turn the field down a bit and then it's
like all of this space
in the room
no
neurological firing
just
then
all of the stuff in the room the stuff
is like that signaling theory of
concepts and all the mental masturbation
and all that type of stuff where it's
only things it's only there's a book
there there's a table there there's a
backpack there there's water there
there's shoes there there's pillows
there there's wood floor there's a book
there
what is going on it's like a it's like a
panic attack
yeah you know what as you're saying it
what it actually reminds me of is uh
when i used to go to
like nightclubs
like there's so much stimulation so much
noise and then you go to the bathroom
and you close the door and it's quiet
whoa
and then it's like do i go back out
there
you open the door
and you're like oh okay
yeah that's what that reminded me of
yeah
and if we just use that analogy to
recognize
if we sort of look at the different
tires in our on our car and we recognize
well
is there a nightclub style dynamic going
on in any of my car tires
analysis paralysis
the overinflation of the mental tire
yeah
should should i potentially just go into
the bathroom
and that's what meditation is yeah right
because you see you intentionally shut
everything out and all of a sudden your
mind's going a thousand thoughts per
second
that's a clear sign that you normally
exist in a nightclub
24 7. so good luck actually being able
to assess
who you are what tires are inflated
there's a nightclub going on in here a
lot of discursive tabs open
and that's the process of like a
meditation is clearing out the nightclub
so you actually have space to think
and that's a lot of what we we provide
in our facilitation is is we help create
that empty space or that that space for
you to actually analyze and assess the
tires because it could be that your your
tires are being stomped on by a bunch of
drunk party-goers and you gotta clear
them out of the room to actually see and
assess
and yes yes if you've ever been to the
club after the club closes
also the club's gone all the people are
gone all the lights are on in the club
and it's just the space and there's some
like trash on the ground and stuff and
yeah you go out and you're like okay
well it's time to clean up the floor and
stuff like
so just these are good there's a good
analogy like this nightclub one's quite
interesting time to clear the energetic
imprint of all the people and the things
that my mind is attached to and being
pulled in different directions
time to call that energy back to you
yeah and all those thoughts actually
imprint your body from a biological
perspective because we're primarily
water and water holds memory and so you
can look at it from neural
wiring and how fast your your brain
waves are but you can also get from a
water memory perspective of all those
thoughts imprint you and so your being
your vehicle has nightclub goers in it
and so you have just to actually cleanse
it and so
part of what we do is really focus on
like replenishing your body with with
pure water so that way it's like taking
a mop on the floor like you gotta mop
off all the spilled drinks that are
there to to be able to to sit down and
and reflect and so
um there is a physical aspect to what we
do with clients as well when they see us
in person
and so
just as you're saying it's all four
tires our procedure our our process and
program isn't just one tire it it's it's
all four tires and when when they're all
in balance they make the fifth which is
your beingness
and so awesome
it's a great way to assess what you're
being and and look at your external
world as how you're showing up and
seeing perhaps where there might be some
some issues with tires so the the
beingness is sort of like the dash in a
sense of the heart like it's kind of
like your presence your your
metaphysical vitals metaphysical vitals
yeah that's great of the vehicle that's
great and so you get little the more
the more your your beingness is awake
aware presence
radiating love oneness service honor
that
the more that the tires
the dash is showing that all is well
there's harmony
and then when a
dissonance
shows up then there's a oh beep beep
beep like look at like
yes and it requires incredible um
surrender to receive that
because it could simply be an ignoring
of the the message in the signal um as
well so it's about building that
awareness practice and also the
surrendering practice
of receiving that signal so that way you
you get it when it's a small sign not
when it's a big car accident a tiny
misalignment yeah
time to rotate your tires focus on these
now
yeah and um
what else
so good
i'm just loving this it's a great play
so good
another good um
like just a simple way to maybe go from
the loud ass nightclub to the bathroom
for a moment to close the door
is just to take a breath
like even that just
yeah and if i might interject a breath
isn't just the breath in
it's the space between the breath in and
the breath out and the breath out and
the space between the breath out and the
breath in so it's actually four parts to
the breath so sometimes people
i've seen and coached where i might take
a deep breath because you're like kind
of need it they go
and they think that's the breath
no that's the breath in the breath is
four parts
and actually there's incredible
enlightenment potential potential
consciousness growing potential in the
space between the breath in and the
breath out
and that's why box breathing is so
powerful physiologically and why it's
trained to like the marines and such
because that breath is is so important
so i just want to add that caveat just
in case like it's not the breath
no that's not a breath it's
in the
in the the box is the
breathe in
hold
out
hold pause yeah
and
so
use that little box method to
just go into the bathroom in the
nightclub for a bit and
just uh like what's what's going on
what's going on like
was there something that happened in my
life in the last like hour that just
went by so fast
that i didn't get a chance to reflect on
well but that was clearly some sort of a
signal or catalyst for for me like the
dash light showed up for one of the
tires but then
it was all going by so fast that it
would
that i had to go into the bathroom for a
bit to actually be able to analyze what
the dash light was saying about the
specific thing
yeah like what's off in my energetic
field because that's what it creates
it's your resonance it's it's how you
show up it's your vibration and that
means everything
in your manifestation potential
that's what you magnetize things to you
with with your beingness
yeah yeah that's so good that's so good
so so basically the sum
of
spiritual emotional
physical and mental
shows up as beingness and then
the
beingness
can be in
we've discussed this as a
as like light dispersion so you get the
visible light spectrum and it also
mirrors the chakras and so
you may be showing up at a yellow level
maybe
your beingness is showing up at a green
level with the heart chakra
and so
the more that your beingness is showing
up at these higher densities these
higher frequencies of love light
awareness
that
that's the more that you gravitate that
feedback loops into your life
so
that's great because it's like an
electromagnetic field resonance
of
vibration that's so important so you're
literally your beingness the status of
your vehicle
is precisely what is
electromagnetizing everything in your
reality it's so good absolutely
and like that's a core thing for the
clients for in the curriculum is like
just that vigilance with that whole
electromagnetic field process and
viewing all its nuances and subtleties
and how it is signaling certain aspects
to your beingness
and having good boundaries around your
beingness
because what because what we all have or
people we work with we're finding they
have incredible superhero abilities yes
and powers that society doesn't know
what to do with and hasn't been rewarded
um or it's just our our generation the
future generations just have these
inherent abilities that are latent
inside you can look at dna and maybe
it's epigenetics it's waiting for the
right environmental context but
you can't
there's a massive challenge being like
the shape of a star if the entire world
only understands the shape of circles
and squares so if we're going to be the
bridge the change makers to live life as
a star
we have to be very clear
that we are stars so that way when other
people's projections of us are like no
you're a square you're a circle you're a
square so you can stand in your
centeredness
and be able to navigate knowing full
well that you are a star
and that's where the boundaries come in
because
for for our our journeys in our
spiritual
gifts and abilities or psych whatever
you want to call these abilities
has been that it it's been but you're
crazy you don't know it it's only given
to you by by this person it's only given
you in this context you can't go out and
do it outside of this context
and so it's about
acknowledging who we are and and
building a relationship
with those those points on the star
and if we don't have the clarity of our
center clarity of our boundaries
we will get sanded down into a a square
or a circle by somebody else
yeah
yeah that's that's a been a core
even still over the last like four years
of
just being really driven by polymath
having learned a lot about a lot of
different things and being really
excited about the synthesis of science
and spirituality and all this type of
stuff and it'd be so interesting people
would always want to be he's a liberal
or he's a conservative or whatever
that's the little square and circle
[ __ ]
or the science and spirituality like
thing like
similar thing like square or circle tell
me which one you're one of the true
and then you know blue or red
um and then whenever your
star or whenever you're purple or
whenever you're
some sort of uh
one of those
uh incomprehensible
geometric things
you can't put a name to
and then people
because
how do i label you how does this fit
into my reality into my reality yes how
does it fit into my framework god is so
freaking it's so liberating that's like
one of the most liberating things is you
can't nail me down
i am the [ __ ] freedom itself
you can't nail me down
and like that's so freeing like that's
and then there's the simultaneity with
that like yeah
there is some sort of an actual apparent
boundary of my own back and so i do go
out and stretch
my back
and so there's like this boundaries
within boundlessness um and so that's
the hilarity of the game is that there
are these apparent
boundaries here within
boundlessness
because there's no distinct there's a
there is an apparent distinction but
then it's also no distinction all just
energy
yeah funny game this is i love what
you're saying about the boundaryless
bound boundlessness
was that it the boundaries in the
boundaries and the boundlessness sorry
because if we're all we come from
oneness and we're all expressions of
source we are each unique expressions of
source otherwise we would just merge
right into each other in the primordial
goo again and like what's the point of
coming here and and like learning our
lessons and becoming who we are and
doing this path of self-discovery inner
work and
seeing what lights up your heart and
pursuing that
as a mission-driven business and exactly
and as you're saying you can't nail me
down so my shorthand will get you very
close to to truth and that's the point
is i don't need to prove truth i i just
have to our role is to help facilitate
your own journey to it so if you want to
nail me down meet me as you the fully
expressed version of you in the present
moment with the fully expressed version
of me
and then and then and then let's see
good luck i'll see you there
and then and then that at least allows
people
who are trying to label you to give them
a pathway versus you can't do it it's
like okay yeah here here's here's the
here's the little tidbit
you know there's a great ver uh
lesson in in i think he's david daida
the the
the book of uh
what what is the way of the superiority
the way of the superior man um and and
uh that the question is like sometimes
the in
in in men or or in women there's this
desire to have multiple lovers and so
what he says is just fully completely
satisfy one woman
or one lover
and then once that happens
then you can consider a second one
because i guarantee you you will never
be able to fully satisfy that other
lover and so that is a beautiful
shorthand to help people on on their way
so just like you're saying
you can't nail me down it's like if you
want to try to nail me down meet me as
the fully expressed version of yourself
in the present moment with with me and
because in your journey to get there
you'll you'll realize that the nailing
down is like a silly thing to try to do
and
to play on this a little further it all
it seems as though
the way to actually be able to emerge
back into the field
at the highest level of honor and
service and compassion
as possible
it requires
in a sense to take all
conditioning and separation and ego and
identity as the costume
and completely dissolve it into the
field itself into that soup into that
oneness into that energy
and then re-emerge from the nothingness
as
what this firework of source is
because then you've traversed
the entirety of what you are
and then you
can serve the field purely
and so that's like that's one of the
core
things that seems to be really important
is like becoming really comfortable with
nothingness becoming really comfortable
with emptiness becoming really
comfortable with your the costume being
just an appearance
that appears and disappears and that
in that process it actually makes you
the sun it makes you more purely the sun
able to actually radiate and illuminate
the field without attachment without
fixation without need to be seen or
validated just purely just in honor and
this would look like for like a
a normal
scenario this would look like when
you're sitting with a friend
and that
your
emptiness would look something like
being totally comfortable with not
needing to insert something into the
space but rather
allowing what your friend is saying to
be heard purely genuinely presently
um
authentically and then you know when
your friend finishes
saying what they say that then you
you lovingly you can just speak through
your glance you don't even need a word
like your eyes themselves non-verbally
can just emit love
and radiance and warmth
and like the more that you hear like
ah man you're really good at listening
or that you you really you know you
really saw me or what like those were
more that like you hear that the better
you're doing at being able to hold space
authentically genuinely all this type of
stuff um
but then also it's the quality of your
you know your question or your insight
that you reflect back at them uh that
then allows also a deeper inquisitive
process into their own
how do you guys feel about that
traversing the entire spectrum into that
nothingness or into that emptiness into
that oneness that then enables you to
re-emerge in the field as pure
how do we feel about it or how what did
it look like yeah
well first of all that was so eloquently
put what you said i just have to like
let it land let your saying yeah because
it's like yeah that is a great litmus
test of how you're doing on the
consciousness journey is are you able to
fully be present with another to listen
and receive
that's like well if you have a nightclub
going on in your head you're not going
to be present and you're going to be a
really horrible friend you know kind of
a thing you're going to be thinking
about what do i say next or what about
dinner what about this or that object oh
that person is cute
right so that presence is a great
practical example and then yeah based on
your own wisdom
and conscious journey how can you then
provide you that reflection that
question and that's something that
victoria's so remarkable at and i just
want to say your analogy is just
absolutely just amazing i i love it
thanks fam
yeah thanks yeah you guys too we've been
we've been on fire since we met it's
been great yeah
yeah so back to the the question yeah
how do we feel so we we take people into
the quantum field
yeah we what we did essentially is we
unplugged well i i guess i'll speak for
myself unplugged from
from reality from society stripping away
the job getting rid of the the apartment
in brooklyn all the stuff selling off
all the things going to india fire
walking on coal
all that all that stuff meditating all
day doing the the powers of the third
eye stuff
but then
coming back and seeing
how do i integrate back into society i
can't connect with my nursing people i
can't connect with my my brooklyn people
my family people they don't understand
this journey i just went on and is this
journey necessary for people looking to
expand their consciousness and their
awareness can you simply go on
a safe
grounded expansive approach
with two skilled guide facilitators who
have taken out some of the guesswork for
you possibly
and
it doesn't uh destabilize you perhaps
like a plant medicine journey would that
that pries open the heart and you
extract that wisdom and that kernel that
seed of what you want to plant
but it also
there's quite an integration that
happens after that so how can we smooth
out the integration process how do we
help them operate with all these
newfound understandings with the
upgraded consciousness
how do we help them re-emerge into
society as who they're being
now who they're becoming who they are
right now
how do they do it now
yeah and everyone has their own unique
journey and so we're specifically
targeting those people who are like hey
we want a little more grounded more
controlled approach than doing like a
plant-based journey which has it's it's
it's its purpose
so it that's really where we connected
in terms of society
and that integration piece is like so
key that victoria
is mentioning because at a lot of
conferences or events in the business
world like i was at the u.s africa
summit and doing lots of things and
talking to
to big leaders and i'm first time i'm
there i'm very you know bright eye like
wow this is all amazing we're going to
make a change in the world and the this
older gentleman just looked at me he's
like
nah
that's just for the headlines we're all
going to go back to our our jobs on
monday
and nothing's going to change
and and and and how that's related to
the spiritual journey in the waking
journey is the integration
you have this ah
but there's no integration
follow-through on it and so what we've
done is it's almost like we've titrated
uh your awakening we've titrated your
your expansion so that way you can
maintain a little more control on on the
massive shift and when we talk about
we're shifting the consciousness of the
planet
there is some form of that to consider
the implications of a massive awakening
happening
in terms of the infrastructure in terms
of individuals lives that are changing
or people who are are almost left behind
when that shift happens because it's
happening i don't know when but it's
happening it's very clear so there will
be people who are like hey what about me
how do i get there right now we're
focused on people who are like i want to
be a leader in it and i want to create
major infrastructure in it but
ultimately full circle will be people
like help me get there and
i don't necessarily know if my
physiology could actually handle a
plant-based journey or a
numerous other reasons why certain
modalities aren't right for them
so that's been um part of the ethos of
what what's come through in our channels
in our sessions as well
and it doesn't have to look as reclusive
as ours did yeah i mean there's there's
no yeah there was a lot of challenge
that that i went through trying to
reintegrate into society massive
trauma
massive dissonance with with my reality
with with people who
i connect with because it was like
almost instantaneous unplugging and if
it's the destination we're all going to
together eventually
then maybe rethinking the approach for
how we can all get there
is really one of the things this
addresses i i think atlas
beautifully said the other day uh
commenting on i forget what question it
was but it was like titrated surrender
[Laughter]
controlled surrender
yeah
yeah
and
for many of us that is basically what
has in a sense happened
there's a
there's a lot of uh non-dual teachers
that will just
say that there was an apparent
contraction energy and then there was an
apparent liberation and energy
and then like that's all they'll say
and they'll kind of like keep
bringing it back to you're already the
wholeness you're already you're already
told you're already you're already over
here and then the question from the
seeker from that which it feels like
it's separate is perpetually but i don't
feel whole why do i not feel whole what
do i do
and so this is the game that some of
these like
some of these seekers that feel separate
play with these doctoral teachers and
it's it's kind of funny um
because there's so much truth in what is
being said about by the non-dual teacher
by the message and yet
there's also
what you could say is like the
simultaneity where you could in a sense
provide a tiny insight into what had
happened in your process
that appear apparently happened as a
process where you went from a contracted
feeling of separation and seeking to a
liberated expanse of feeling of freedom
and wholeness
and so then you could drop a little
insight for
that which feels separate
and so then there's some sort of a
titration of awakening or of
remembering
after forgetting
seven years
and more
so it's it seems to be really critical
for people to recognize that there is
both no journey
because you're already it already whole
and yet there is the appearance of some
sort of a journey
um
and then
yeah what comes to me on that is a
visual
uh and and it's a symphony life is a
symphony and those those non-dual
teachers are kind of like the big gong
like dong that gets banged like every
you know
fourth or eighth you know
uh
chord or whatever it's called bar yeah
fourth or eighth bar like it's important
we gotta come back to that but there's
so much that happens in the space in
between that that we're not addressing
or or expressing or appreciating which
is like maybe you have the cello come in
maybe you have the the bongos maybe you
have the piano or the flute come in and
and those are important pieces to the
human experience as well because um
when i've basically
disappeared into the ether
into the akashic beyond the akash
whatever you want to call it the quantum
field it gets lonely and i've talked to
several people who who have done this
before it's like what do you do once
you're once you're on the mountain well
you come back down the mountain because
you want more people to have fun with
you and we're seeing this happen in
society in terms of technological
adoption
is like it requires a certain level of
consciousness to be able to keep up with
the technology and and with how it it
replicates itself in societal structures
and when when you talk about being able
to download channel certain technologies
that are really fun and cool to play
with the question is from a
responsible perspective is humanity
ready for it and and the ethics of
technology comes up and and and the
conversation of of ai of like uh you
know
mass
like like bombs and nuclear warfare
comes up of is our consciousness ready
for it you know are we ready to have the
technology to instantly manifest
anything you want
well if you're constantly thinking about
a hundred different things that is
actually
like a death sentence because of all the
thought like if everything you thought
manifested
oh my gosh you'd be dead and that's one
of the lessons that they teach you it's
like the kaupataru tree is one of the
things that that our teacher taught is
oh sit under the kalpataru tree and any
wish you you want or anything you think
of what will come true so he's like oh i
want jewels oh my gosh i and jules
appeared oh i want gold oh my gosh gold
appeared and then he thought oh my gosh
what if someone comes into the tiger
comes and tries to eat me and then there
came a tiger yeah
i love that one that's such a good one i
love that
god that one little fearful thought
comes
manifest and then bye bye yeah that's
great
exactly so consciousness almost has like
uh well there's that other part to it
too where it's like now you need for all
your
diamonds and gold you need uh a place to
store it safely you need guards to
yeah
that's the story of like the the
fisherman down in in mexico where the
the young mba you know comes and is like
hey you do so well there's so many fish
here you know why don't you take a you
know take take a loan or take investors
to grow your business and then you could
have many boats and and it's like why
would i do that if i have many boats i
have to hire many people and then i have
i have the the the people who invested
in my company i have to deal with and
then and then i have to deal with them
and then i have to deal with running a
company and i don't want to run a
company i just want to fish and be with
my family before you know you're in your
head and out of your heart about why you
did it in the first place yeah and i
take money i don't get to spend time
with my family why would i do that
that's what my heart wants
i like fishing i don't want to run a
company i want to be a fisherman
so so your idea of expansion actually is
like
repulsive because you're not seeing the
implications of this this tool you have
which is your mind and expanding it like
business is a technology in and of
itself and there's like a spiritual
component to it as well and a
metaphysical component um but that's
something that as an mba myself i love
talking about is that it's a technology
and that there is a spiritual aspect to
that technology that is is very often uh
ignored and it goes back to the
origination of the thought current that
conceived the business
when it was
at ideation at conception from what
vibration or from what
unfulfilled need it was coming from
and what does that
person's wholeness or lack of wholeness
who created
said entity how does that impact
the growth and scaling and expansion and
permeation into our society
has that person done the shadow work and
understood all the implications of what
this can do
and and and if not it manifests in
different ways in terms of how it grows
or how it fails what the company culture
is like the hiring policies it shows up
in in small ways that we really work
with them at the pre-inception of idea
or pre-receiving of their dharma so that
way they do the shadow work so it's like
hey maybe you just need to like heal
with with your mom which is a very
challenging topic for many people but
you know tell your mom you love her like
work through the connection issue before
you decide to build a company that
essentially you're building to try to
meet that unmet need that your mom never
gave you
and we started out with the the foundry
process like taking a business from
ideation to basically grounding it into
this dimension as a business venture
right and then we had to take a few
steps backwards
and
create this kind of precursor it's like
where did that seed come from is this
the right seed you're planting for you
where what space did it come from what
unresolved issues might there be that
will manifest and permeate throughout
the business
so we had to ki reverse engineer and
work backwards
and and solve for some of the issues
that founders encounter on their
entrepreneurial journey yeah because for
me the foundry process was like oh my
gosh i have the second line ecosystem
idea in my head okay well how do i move
forward on it so this process was kind
of birth with that and and individuals
who received
unique channels or very expensive
channels that are very out there very
future oriented how do you ground it
into the present moment to be like okay
well we need one project manager and we
need one you know back end coder and
this and that no well what we could do
is we could do the nft and then we could
attach it with this and this and that
that and then we could use the gematri
of this and that it's like okay like
your ideas are beautiful and if that is
your dharma awesome we need to ground
that and that was the process but then
what we saw was that the individual had
to go through a process before being
able to fully steward that idea forward
introspection elevating vibration tuning
your vessel because if this is a massive
multi-dimensional idea you want to make
sure you're tuned to carry its resonance
perfect
yeah especially when we're looking at
fortune 500 ceos or we're looking at the
2 200 billionaires on the planet 225 000
ultra high net worth on the planet
that's 30 million or more in u.s dollars
in assets
the president's um
the
all the attendees at the general
assembly united nations
um
the
535 people in the united states congress
so you look at all these little pockets
of people that are
probably nearly
representing like seven billion or
something people probably
and then there's all the
interpenetration and interweaving of
somebody that
does something with
amazon
and then also as part of the us
so there's the congress one and the
amazon one
and then there's also some and then
jeff basis being a billionaire so
there's that part to it as well and so
now you're just weaving all this
complexity and so you're wondering well
these this big swath of the most
influential people like what is their
level of consciousness or like you know
are they are they are they entering into
the fields from a place of something
that happened when they were three years
old then they're still seeking
validation or worthiness
something on unhealed trauma
is it
and how to
make it so that
this style of understanding our
interscape
becomes the core of what is talked about
at the un general assembly or at the
davos world economic forum because this
is it like this is the thing like this
is the thing um i haven't been able to
find anything else that's the thing as
much as this like diving inwards
with earnestness honor integrity love
compassion for yourself and for the
world
is the best thing that you can possibly
do
and so on like the individual level with
doing work with
both people that may have businesses may
not have businesses small businesses
medium businesses good stuff very good
grassroots very good very important very
important grassroots very important
also the most impactful top-down
influence is also very very very
important getting
to
that
so
so so crucial yeah you're so on point
like
um
as i said i grew up in the newspaper
industry and our family owned a major
newspaper in beverly hills
and
to your point there are billionaires
wanting the publisher of the newspaper
to sit at their table because they knew
that that would mean a photo on the
front page
and
everyone invited the publisher to the
event because they wanted the picture
and so you have these these titans of
industry
asking for the publisher to be there and
it became almost a social thing of oh
did you see that
my photo was on the front page of the
picture of the paper
so i took that same principle
and applied it to the to the us africa
summit
i put together a a magazine
that
had
a beautiful picture of each one of the
african presidents beautiful thing
written about them
and and ended up going there it it
it they asked for a second
run of it i had like a 500
uh budget and an incredible team
but i show up there and everyone wants
it
their president's asking for more copies
of it or president delegates asking for
more copies of because they want to give
it to their friends because it says
something nice about them
and that led me to actually have
meetings with with certain african
countries heads of commerce and
marketing because they wanted something
written nice about about their
country and it's the same principle
beautiful picture nice words power of
positivity and and this was before i had
gone through any form of an awakening
journey and i'm like what the heck did i
just walk into
this the the same principle that applies
to like a beverly hills housewife is the
same motivating factor that applies to
heads of state
and and that to me was just an
astonishing factor and and it proves to
your poi it goes to your point of like
therefore healing yourself is the most
important thing going inside is the most
important thing
as well as not just digging out the
trauma which sometimes these programs
might just focus on heal your past heal
your past heal your past no create your
future
and part of creating your future is
healing your past the end goal is not to
heal your past the angle is to create
your future
and that gives your new narrative
that gives you the motivation to heal
from a positive aspect because i know
that that's something that
you've journeyed with pretty intensely
yeah i was doing endless shadow work
going in burning down the forest pulling
out the weeds never planting any seeds
not not understanding like what was the
purpose i was doing it all for so it can
be a spiritual trap on the path where
you go in and you just constantly
pick at yourself i'm not good enough i'm
not worthy enough i'm not uh
nobody cares about what i have to say
who am i to go and talk about the these
topics anything like that
without actually creating something and
writing the new narrative overriding the
old beliefs reprogramming
what's your why
going within seeing what what drives you
what propels you to want to create this
what excites you and what lights you up
i love how you guys have been using that
throughout our conversation of what
lights you up
you know what's in your highest
excitement what are you blueprinted for
so exciting what's your calling what's
your north star
love these it's very powerful
but it's not coming from a place of lack
that's the core thing like
like my
my actualization is not coming from a
place of unwholeness or unworthiness
it's kind of like a flower that just
naturally blossoms to the sun and emits
an aroma and
it's not like
so we just got to be very careful with
why because it can be uh
because it plays into that mystery that
we were talking about a couple nights
ago you know which is very important
it's very very important like
to sort of in that that titrated
surrender like letting go like let
go ease your way into like the flower
like the flower doesn't have a little
[ __ ] mind on top of it that's going
you know type thing so
like careful with that like so there's
like a
coming from wholeness you know what are
you blueprinted for what's your unique
artistic expression etc yeah it's
beautiful it's beautiful because because
we're also that which
is
beautifully artistically expressing
itself via this dance and so to also
be like
nothingness
is also like emptiness is empty
like don't be drunk on emptiness
yeah
yeah absolutely
one of the things that i found is that
when it comes to like a spiritual
concept of dharma
regardless of whether you're coming from
a place of lack or wholeness you'll at
least have some understanding of the
general concept of what your dharma is
it may be filled in with a lot of the
trauma and the incompletion in the lack
but it at least is a starting point that
as you do the inner work it clarifies
more and more what that dharma is
so you don't have to i just sit there
from an empty place before pursuing
something
um it's just a recognition that as you
do the inner work the the dharma that
you're pursuing gets clarified and will
will
evolve at the level of consciousness
that you are
at and and the traumas and triggers or
subconscious programming negative
beliefs
that you have are being projected onto
what you perceive that dharma is but as
you said like get on the horse and then
i can help you with riding a horse
unless you get on the horse like that's
the first step so acknowledge and
appreciate this idea of a concept of
dharma
because that to me is like the highest
spiritual ideal of your doingness
and so you're you're doing it from the
level at your beingness and we can help
you refine and go through the
evolutionary process of your beingness
and that will translate to the evolution
of your doingness but get on the horse
and start from that perspective
beautiful yeah
um gosh just love that
that's so good and i love the car
analogy with the tires and the beingness
being and i just
i love that just so good so good just
really really well done in general first
podcast
pretty pretty pretty [ __ ] good uh
thank you i loved it thank you
you're a great host yeah we we resonate
i mean yeah it is that which comes
through us that's why we don't call
ourselves
coaches really or teachers we're
facilitators like there are certain
roles where we play teachers certain
roles we play coaches but ultimately
we're facilitating we're facilitating
the divine to come through based on the
level of resonance of this container
that you've created so this is equally a
representation of your profundity your
profoundness your depth because what we
realize is that we're essentially
language architects to help bring people
to source based on their comprehension
of it and so it could be as simple as
talking about one plus one is two or it
could go to this depth in this level and
that's just an acknowledgement of who
you are the intention of what it is that
you're doing and the intentionality of
your your viewers and why they're
watching you
so thank you for
yeah for being you and
and watching the the deeper the the
field coherence the heart resonance
that's present the deeper we can go the
quicker we can unlock and reveal things
and
co-create
damn that was really good too with
really just kind of being a language
architect in a sense as you facilitate
people's
journey to unite with source with what
they are that's
yeah yeah yeah i like that
yeah because that goes to the first
point that you guys mentioned with how
you
your intake is vibrationally you're
parsing the essence and then serving it
uniquely to each one
yeah and we're solving the the inherent
separation that language is
totally totally and you'll notice that
some of these greatest poets and mystics
and stuff they talk about
just how much we overuse
words
and how so much love is lost with that
overuse of words
like you just go outside
into nature
and just be quiet
quiet the mind and just feel from your
heart look at this it's a [ __ ]
miracle baby
yeah a rival the movie arrival really
dives into like the separation of
language and creating a unity language
of beingness yes
yes yes yes
this was so good thank you thank you
thank you for your awakened presence you
too
thanks everyone for tuning in
infinite love for you as well thank you
thank you
we would love to
hear from you in the comments below let
us know how you feel about the episode
any core insights core takeaways let us
know
also
like the video helps the algorithm
subscribe to the channel if you haven't
yet
also
share the video with other people that
you feel like this would positively
resonate with and influence well
also check out the link in the bio below
so faces of the future dot co right cool
faces of future dot code the links in
the bio below
and
the batches that you intake are
they're not just batches they're kind of
any time people can come in and then
also
the
general length is about three months
and then it can be remote or in person
in the la area yes yes we do the two
two-on-one journeys and then they join a
group or our our community
our pool yeah because we're not just
gonna upgrade your consciousness we're
gonna make sure it's it's fully
integrated and we're gonna help help you
navigate that path to self-realization
self-accountability
and everyone's on their unique journey
on their unique pace and so one of the
things that's important for us is to
make sure that you feel fully supported
and safe in this it's not just a
one-shot and go kind of thing and it's
creating a community as well at that
level of consciousness so
it is a beautiful series of things that
you can
experience with us
perfect and then one of the things i was
just coming up was that to weave these
communities also together as well
because what we're doing with the no
limit society what you guys are doing
face of the future what every single one
of these
groups
of
awakened
presence consciousness is doing to like
weave into some like
one million person festival in africa
in 2022 in the summer you know something
nuts
that would be so lit we're gonna do that
oh
it's beautiful it's more realistic than
you might
oh it's so coming
it's so in the field this whole
collective's awakening it's so dope
it's so coming i'm glad you picked up on
it
[ __ ] yeah
oh this has been so warm okay all right
thank you thank you thank you thank you
thank you thank you thanks everyone
infinite love talk to you soon
peace